my personal philosophy would be not to
have a personal philosophy no I think
the short answer is no or at least I've
never thought about it and I guess if
you haven't thought about it you don't
have one no not really I mean sort of
you know culture and religious culture
and things but not not whether I'm
straight with God well that's pretty
close to personal philosophy in this
well my father had very good advice
about that it's the only advice I can
ever remember his giving me he was not a
you know heart-to-heart sort of father
he was a good father but not a come in
my study and we're going to have a
heart-to-heart I actually never met a
father like that so maybe they only in
the movies but my father used to say you
might as well be a mensch a Manchus is a
German word and also a Yiddish word and
in Germany means human being and Yiddish
it means an upright person in big things
and small things so he would not only
men she would not only come to the aid
of a friend and even if it is peril but
also if he borrowed your apartment would
leave it slightly nicer than he found it
and I was always impressed about way my
father put it my father grew up in st.
Joe Missouri and spoke very much like
Harry Truman even though he was born in
the Ukraine it came as an infant and he
and he used phrases like haven't had so
much fun since the Hogs egg little
sister and stuff like that but he said
you he always said you might as well be
a mensch I mean it was never you know
our family is you know was our honor
depends on it or anything like that it
was a sort of considered the
alternatives and and at the end decided
you might as well be a mensch it's a
sort of a Midwestern way to phrase it
you